hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game between Peter Svidler and
magnus carlsen it's it's a match
basically that celebrates the
anniversary the 15 University of just 24
and they are about to play a match first
to five wins draws counting of course
and well that's that will decide the
victor and this is Game four I decided I
will show only game four as it's the one
I thought it would be the most
interesting to show and you are welcome
to check out all the other games I will
put the links to their official streams
in the description below there will be a
link to Carlsen stream so you can watch
that you can also watch stream with
Swedish commentary so you can watch that
it's some two hours watching material
combined so you know it's it's a Monday
go wild and also I will include a third
link but I will mention that at the end
of the game so without further ado this
is Game four we're gonna talk about the
results of the match after I show you
the game sweedler goes for efore
crossing goes c5 the Sicilian defense 90
to f3 nice to see six and for those of
you sore about that who are wondering
about the title we'll get to that
and here Carlsen mentions in the stream
you are about to see that if you visit
the link that s wheeler most likely will
not go for d4 against him and fiddler
does not he goes for Knight to c3 we
have E 5 by Carlsen now taking this
advantage of taking holded of the d4
square but also making a a hole on the
d5 square for whites to use and there we
have it again the elusive green square
Bishop to c4 by Svidler and now g6 and
here across and said that he had a
disposition in his game against max few
Maxie Marshall a Grove in 2018 in round
one of the seen field Cup where Maxime
went immediately for h4 and h5 but
here's Fiddler goes for a different way
he was for d3 we have h6 by Carlsen and
now comes nice to d2 we have d6 by
Carlsen and not nice to f1 now valeurs
night is coming all the way to e3 and
from there both Knights will be
controlling not this square but the d5
square and we have Bishop to g7 and it
was somewhere around this point that
Carlsen mentioned that to put it
delicately that this is a
an fu factor variation has it black sort
of a black can play like distance and
still be okay but you know feel free to
check it out to get the full idea behind
it we have nice - III now Silla really
controls the d5 square and the Knight G
to e7 with castles by settler castles by
Carlsen
and now comes a three at the games I
don't know if I mentioned our blitz it's
a five plus zero so no no increment you
have to be you know watchful of your
time crossing our place King gauge 7 he
wants to get his King off of this
diagonal so he can put the f5 pawn
Knight eat the d5 grabbing control of
the d5 square cross and exchanges once
Knight captures and now he can finally
push f5 we have each captures on a 5 and
now not G captures cross says that f4
for white would weaken blacks position
too much especially you know since it's
a blitz game so Bishop captures on f5
rush up to D to developing the the
bishop and Queen to d7 now cross and
says that he is feeling more and more
okay in his position he's preparing to
play this Queen d7 the bishop is coming
to e6 and Carson will now also start to
fight for the d5 square with b4 by
settler now comes rush of the e6 and B
captures on c5 d captures on c5 and now
comes Knight - III not a problem for for
black as black now uses this very nice
diagonal to get rid of his weak isolated
e5 pawn here across and pushes for the
rook is under attack and the now comes
look to be won and here Bishop captures
on c4 with D captors and c4 Knight
Capra's on c4 is also possible but it
would be captures on c4 also this will
again create a nice outpost for the
knight on d5 so D captors on c4 and now
comes Luke 8 to d8
now Carson is threatening to win
material here with Queen captures on d2
and we have Knight to d5 just a very
nice outpost for sailors night but there
is a problem cross and goes Knight to e5
pressuring the c4 pawn and here is
wheeler defends it but it's not enough
here for the first time in this video
for free
the video and try to find the best
continuation for black for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent you know a taker of
the advantages left by white and for
those who just want enjoyed show tonight
captures in c4 as we already mentioned
the Queenie to move is not enough to
guard the c4 pawn and now Queen must
capture so Queen captures on c4 and now
comes Queen captures on d5 and to make
matters worse you also have to exchange
Queens because the bishop on d2 is
hanging so Queen captures rook captures
now again you don't have time to grab b7
as the bishop on d2 is still hanging
Bishop d3 and now crossing consolidates
would be six so if you look at the
position now or bishops of same colors
both players have two rooks and Colson
is up upon both first three pawn islands
so it's it will be an interesting
endgame especially since it's blue it's
with a four wheeler wants to get rid of
his isolated pawn and he wants to
exchange it for Carlson's be pawn and
cross and does not wish to allow this he
goes to Bishop to c3 to take control of
the a five squares so Bishop to c3 rook
F the d1 offering a trade of rooks and
now rook F to d8 cousin doesn't mind but
he wants to trade rooks on his own terms
rook captures rook captures and now King
to F one switch starts to bring the King
into the game
we have h5 by crossing he also wants to
bring the King into the game but first
he wants to get rid of this H upon being
a constant target
you could also instead of h6 go g5 but
then your pawns are on dark squares
which still makes them targets and you
know a white could block the deposition
completely with g4 so a cousin goes h5
and also I believe he mentioned during
the stream that he doesn't want to
embarrass himself in front of a lot of
people by playing g5 instead of h5 and
you know just in case it turns out that
it's oh it's bad kingi 2 we have King g7
now cross and also starts to bring his
King into the game
rook to b3 pressuring the Bishop Bishop
to a5 a constant mentioned that it some
might not be the best Square for the
bishop but that you know it gets the job
done still
white doesn't have the option of pushing
any pawns and here silver goes for rook
to b5 and the Carson mentions that he's
sort of threatening c4 but you know not
I I didn't really understand what was
the threat behind c4 and you know it's
it's still not all that clear to me but
here Carson has a a pretty simple plan
he plays Bishop to b4 and now the threat
is rook d6 and a6 trapping the rook on
b5 so Bishop to F for not allowing rook
to d6 but here across and just brings
the King deeper into the position
fiddler goes Bishop to b8 attacking the
a7 pawn but now just rip the d7 we have
King to e3 by cellular and here Carson
just has a winning move so once again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for Carson I will
give you a couple of seconds as usual
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just defeated
Peter Svidler and for those of you who
just want to enjoy show rook to b7 is
the move course and played and it was in
this position unmoved 34 that Peter
Svidler resigned to the game the bishop
has to move once you move the bishop
let's say any square a6 is coming the
rook is trapped and you have to go into
this very very bad endgame for black
where you will be down the exchange
after pawn captures and now white will
win the e4 pawn but then just black
continues and it's 5 to 5 points but
constant has a rook against the bishop
and fiddler was also much lower on time
so he didn't drag it out after Luke - b7
civil or simply resigned the game so
game four whence the Carson and the
final score was a five and a half to
half in Coulson's favor so they played
six games one of the games as fiddler
was able to draw and Carson said that
well even before they asked him if water
his chances in the mansion he said that
he thinks his chances are good but
mostly because us wheeler thinks too
highly of course and and he he he
doesn't realize how bad Magnus will
actually play this so in the first games
fiddler was better but then calls and
just blundered the rook second game I
think also pretty equal if and then
Colson was just able to win it third
game was a draw then comes this very
nice victory but Carlson and then to our
two hundred victories make the result
five and a half - half swim that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that's
you know in blitz it's very hard to
counter Carlson but as far as the
classical chess goes not that but here
we have as you can see Switzer still has
a positive result against Magnus Carlsen
in classical chess
two wins one loss and 15 draws Carlson
had an opportunity in the last year's
European Club Cup when they played but
it was also a draw
so at least at least wheeler can still
boast boast to that and also it's it's
really a very important game the ones we
won against Carlson in the 2013 can this
tournament I don't know if you were
subscriber on this channel when we were
covering the the short Coulson saga
where we covered the 2013 candidates
tournament and his match against we
found out our anand but if you haven't
also the third link in the description
below will be the one where swiller
plays against caution in the 2013
candidates also a very nice game and and
a very important one almost became a
historic one at that so and like I
mentioned first and second link will be
a direct link to the stream by Magnus
Carlsen and or Peter Svidler for from
their own streams of this match so we
can enjoy all the professional comments
as well sure once again that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Madison asta Nielsen Nazari brain
Chuck jeremy Hulbert Zachary stencil and
Benjamin Berkley for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content continuing to cover Blancas saga
and the checking up on what whatever is
going on in the in the chess world thank
you all and I will see you soon